[Music]
congratulations on the book thank you
I mean two months later and you're still
in the New York Times bestseller list
it's crazy it's crazy yeah so what are
you like when you think about that like
what do you attribute like what is it
about the book that you think is
connecting with people you know much I
think that everybody sees pieces of
themselves and the people that I'm
writing about including my story and I
think that's what we read for I think a
lot of the time we want to see our lives
reflected and someone else's experience
and I think that it's resonating because
it's it's nonfiction these are real
people
and I think so much of the time we think
oh I'm the only one who thinks that or
feels that or does that and then when
you see other people who are doing that
or thinking that or feeling that you
know I think that's such a profound
experience yeah I also think that as
somebody who's been in therapy in and
out of therapy for many years I found
myself sitting across from my therapist
thinking like what is this person's life
all about and there's such a conscious
effort to you know maintain that barrier
and that boundary and for you to peel
that back and reveal your humanity I
think is unique and and super
interesting and I don't know whether
it's comforting or disturbing to find
out your therapist is actually a human
being you know going through a lot of
the same challenges that we all go
through right you know I talked about
that tension in the book between wanting
your therapist to be a human being who
has life experience you know nobody
wants to go and talk to a robot or a
brick wall but on the other hand I think
there's that tension because people want
your therapist want their therapists who
have worked everything out to kind of be
ahead of that yeah
well at the same time I think what I
just lost my train of thought what am I
trying to say
I'm interested in let me just restart
that thought I mean I I'm interested in
how this is affected your your practice
going forward in the sense that you know
as somebody who's looked at my therapist
and thought I don't know anything about
this person now you're sitting across
from people who presumably have read
your book and now know a lot about you
is that changed the wet your therapeutic
modality or what that relationship looks
like it's interesting because I didn't
know how that would affect the people
that I'm currently seeing so all the
people that I write about are people
that I'm no longer saying and when I got
back from book tour you know sometimes
people would come in and sit down on the
couch and the first thing they'd say is
so I read your book which I never
mentioned my book before I left I just
said I'm going to be away on these dates
and so we you know would talk about it
in terms of them in terms of their
experience of reading the book and what
it was like for them to read that yeah
but you know don't try to keep that
boundary up oh yeah we you know we
didn't we didn't talk about the things
that I talked about in the book because
it's not helpful for them they're there
for them yeah you know other people came
in and haven't said a word and I I'm
sure they know about the book
but you know I think that for them it's
more comfortable which I understand it's
more comfortable for them to kind of
compartmentalize that part the writing
part of my life from the fact that they
have this therapeutic relationship with
me yeah one of the things you talk about
is is never you know Google yeah of
course everyone who's sitting with you
has or or you know knows these things
about you ought to imagine there's a
there's probably a pretty big influx of
people now that are trying to become
your patients right and the irony is
that I thought that once I wrote this
book nobody would want to be my patient
just because they would know too much
you know not that there's anything
strange about what I reveal in the book
but just that you they now have a lot of
information about me that they wouldn't
have about another therapist but I think
it speaks to
you talk about and you know an issue
that that you know I feel strongly about
which is when you have the courage to be
vulnerable on that level and to show
your humanity it creates connectivity
you think it's gonna repel people but
actually it magnetizes them to you it
does and I that was a big message of the
book was you know you see the people in
the book as they struggle to kind of
keep you away from whatever they're the
truth of who they are yes and they think
that they'll be more you know better
liked better more well respected and
that if they show the truth of who they
are that people will run yeah and
instead people are drawn toward that
that's the glue that that connects
people why is it so hard though why is
it so hard for us to just be honest I
mean I'm a pathological people pleaser
you know I've had many experiences
therapy you know you talk about this too
like trying to win over the therapist or
you know not being honest because I just
want to you know covet or a curry favor
with the person yeah yeah there is a
performative aspect I think when people
first come in for a lot of people not
everybody where you know they they want
the therapist to find them you know
entertaining witty smart filigree with a
lot of what you say even though they
don't necessarily agree with it and you
know you you look for that as a
therapist are they are they trying to
get me to like them and is that getting
in the way of us having a much more
authentic conversation so when someone
comes in and you can sense that what is
this strategy for getting them to you
know open up a little bit more peel back
that layer well I think you know
sometimes in LA to you have people who
are maybe like comedy writers have been
coming in there they're sort of you know
they feel like they're in the writers
room and they're they're you know trying
to be funny and and hey look at me and
I'm not responding to that in the way
that they want me to respond to that
you know therapy isn't the cocktail-hour
it's it's it's it's a mask right right
and and in this room I'm saying to them
by my
lack of response right in this room
we're gonna do something different than
you do out there mm-hmm that's scary it
is scary so even for people who are not
you know we're not doing this job of
trying to entertain people we all try to
entertain people that's what we do out
in the world that's our social face and
and the therapy room is about hey I'm
gonna see something about you that you
are trying to hide and you're gonna find
that it's actually beautiful hmm
well we all have these blind spots that
you know kind of create you know
repetitive crises and problems in our
lives and no matter it's sort of like
you know until you reach that point
where you're in sufficient amount of
pain as a result of this it's very
difficult to identify that or to see it
and it takes someone like yourself to be
able to point that out I'm curious about
what you've learned about how we you
know why is it that it's so difficult
for us to see these things that
continually trip us up that are perhaps
easily identifiable to the people that
are around us it's so much easier to
it's kind of like having like on a
google map right if you can zoom out you
can see things so much more clearly so
the other people have the vantage point
of not living our lives they're outside
of our lives and so so much of the time
people will come in and they're
complaining about something external
that the problem is their partner their
child their parent their boss their
co-worker this the society the culture
you know whatever it is and all of those
things might be true but at the same
time what are they doing that is you
know it's almost like they're shooting
themselves in the foot and they're over
and over and over and they end up stuck
in the same place and they can't see
that their response to whatever's going
on in the world is part of the problem
too that they have a role in their own
lives right a lot of people will come in
and act like you know the world is
happening to me and I have
I have no agency in this right you call
it the presenting problem right somebody
comes in I'm in a relationship crisis or
something's happening at work or
whatever it is and your process is to
then get behind that and look at the
behaviors and the actions and the
responses that have kind of cultivated
that repetitive situation in their lives
over time yeah yeah I always like to say
that I'm listening for the music under
the lyrics that they're telling me about
a situation and I'm kind of listening
for well what is the underlying struggle
or pattern that got you into this
situation in the first place and this is
something so different from what our
friends do so if you tell your friends
something I talk in the book about the
difference between idiot compassion and
wise compassion idiot compassion is what
our friends do yeah he's a jerk yeah
you're right you're absolutely right
that person wronged you
wise compassion is what a therapist does
which is we hold up the mirror and help
people see their reflection in a way
that nobody else is going to do for them
mm-hmm but why is it what is the the
rationale or the thinking behind the not
reluctance but the kind of refusal
actually to give proactive advice like
you see these people come in
I'm sure the problems are very similar
to each other with all the patients that
you've treated I would imagine that you
can easily identify within moments like
what this person's core thing is and and
do you have to hold yourself back from
saying listen you just need to like see
this thing and stop doing this one thing
about therapy is that is that we have
the answer right and we're withholding
it for some reason I have this word
taped up in my office ultra crepin
Arianism which is it's translates
roughly to the habit of giving advice
outside of one's knowledge or competence
and the reason that I love that word is
because I may know what I would do in
that situation but I don't know what you
should do in that situation because I
can't live your life for you so part of
it is so part of it is that there there
are a few other reasons too one is that
when you come in and tell me a story
you're telling me the story through your
lens
if other people involved in the story
were also to tell me the story I'd have
so much more information that might
change my advice right because you're
telling me this story you know and
you're almost gunning for me to take a
position and so if I had a broader sense
of the problem by knowing like what are
the other people doing in this story - I
might that might alter the advice that I
would give so I might be giving bad
advice if I'm only giving it based on
your one version of the story and the
other part of it is that we want to
encourage people's independence we want
people to be able to make better choices
in their own lives so if every time they
need to make a decision they say oh I've
got to ask my therapist well we're doing
you a disservice it's like with your
children you want them to grow up and be
able to not need you in the same way
anymore it almost feels like inception
like you need them to come to this
realization on their own so that they
can own it and fully comprehend it for
themselves rather than being told like
to establish some level of agency and
and deep self understanding
self-knowledge around these issues so
that they can you know kind of rewire
their brains to respond in a different
and healthier manner right so many
people are making decisions based on
some historical artifact that they're
carrying around from their past in terms
of how they think about themselves or
the world like if their narrative is
something like nothing will ever work
out for me or their narrative is I'm
unlovable they're gonna make choices
through that lens so one of the jobs of
therapy is to help them see this is this
narrative this faulty narrative that
you're walking around with and it's it's
influencing the way that you make
decisions on a daily basis yeah but why
can't you just tell them that we do or
you do oh yeah we're not like these you
know ciphers who are holding back
information we want people to leave as
soon as they can you know but we
sometimes people aren't ready to hear
something so you have to say it in in
lots of different ways and timing and
dosage are so important right how do you
gauge that like how do you get to the
point where you
you believe someone's ready to hear
something that you've been waiting to
say for a long time you floated out
there and you see what their response is
and if they recoil you backtrack a
little bit
you don't backtrack meaning you don't
take back what you said but you say okay
I'm gonna have to go in a different way
or I'm gonna have to time this
differently I'm gonna have to plant some
seeds before they're ready to really
look at this and what's the process when
somebody comes into your office they sit
down and they say I'm just not fulfilled
or I have some low-grade anxiety or
depression or I just feel a little bit
lost but I don't have any identifiable
childhood trauma there's no big inciting
incident
there's no precipitating event that I
can you know look to as an explanation
for how I feel I'm just confused and and
you know I don't know what to do like
how do you unpack that I would imagine
that's a pretty common yeah condition it
is so we look at what is going on in
this person's life and as they start to
talk often what happens is there is more
going on I don't mean that they had
childhood trauma I just mean that the
situation is more complicated than they
initially presented it right and and
that just that's a process of slowly
peeling back the layers and learning
more about their life or how does that
look for your from where you yeah you
have to really get to know somebody and
sometimes you have to help them get to
know themselves you know a lot of people
come in and they think that they know
themselves and they don't necessarily
know some key pieces of information
about themselves you know what makes
them tick or how they're relating to
people so that's really important and I
think the other thing is sometimes
sometimes it's a case of the person
doesn't really know him or herself very
well but sometimes it's a case of
getting to unknown meaning you have this
idea about yourself that is holding you
back and you need to unknown at because
it's not it's it's limiting you yeah we
all have these stories that we tell
ourselves about who we are and why we do
what we do and
we react and behave in the in the manner
that we do and the more I kind of learn
about this world the more I realize that
these stories are essentially fallacies
you know in the in the positive and in
the negative well they're very
subjective and I think none of us want
to think that we all want to think that
are the stories that we're telling our
very objective here's what happened
here's what he said then I said this
then he said this and here's what
happened and it feels very objective
when you're telling the story and that's
why I wanted to include my own story in
the book because you can see my
evolution as I go from this person who
has this very you know clear-cut in my
mind story about what happened with my
boyfriend and as we start to unpack this
it becomes much more nuanced right so
tell the story a little bit so people
understand I mean basically you're in a
relationship and the guy decides to
leave which is a big surprise to you and
this kind of you know leads you into you
know a journey of self-discovery of your
own yeah so you know originally I was
gonna write about these four patients
and not include my story but this is
what was going on while I was seeing
these four patients I was going to get
married to this boyfriend and we were
planning to get married we talked about
it all the time we had you know I was
about to move in with him and you know
he had just checked with his HR
department about whether he could put my
son on the medical insurance when we got
married you know who was - it was not it
was not like some vague idea and
imagining this right right exactly and
and then one night um we're just having
a normal conversation and he gets quiet
in this way there's not the comfortable
silence that you know people in couples
are you know used to and really enjoy
and I notice that his foot is shaking
like kind of up and down and I see
what's up and and you know nothing yeah
but what comes out is he's decided he
can't live with a kid under his roof for
the next ten years that kid is my
eight-year-old who had not been hiding
in a closet the entire time that we were
dating and he'd been really grappling
with us but he didn't
tell me because he really wanted to be
able to work this out for himself he
really wanted to get past this feeling
of of oh my god I'm gonna have to sort
of you know go back to this
child-raising part when my kids are
about to leave for college and I was
really looking forward to the empty nest
and he just didn't tell me about it the
whole time that you know it he wasn't
grappling with it the whole time it was
had been going on for a few months for
him and and finally he he tells me this
and we could just like picked our movie
for the weekend you know it was one of
those things where you're kind of like
when were you gonna tell me and how is
this gonna come up so my version of the
story and I very intentionally say my
version of the story was that you know
he's a jerk I mean how could you how
could you date someone for this long and
say you're gonna marry this person and
and get to know this person's child and
then all of a sudden come to this
conclusion when the kid was there the
whole time
right did you also feel like the fact
that you're a therapist the second
therapist that you should have been able
to see these signs coming along the way
oh that must have been you know
compounded the confusion of the whole
experience for you right and I think
that's why I stuck to my story so
vehemently because if I acknowledged
that I had missed all these things then
what did that say about me right and and
you should be somebody who doesn't have
blind spots
so the realization is sort of well even
though I do this for a living and I know
all this stuff I still don't fully
understand my own internal roadmap yeah
yeah and I think you know as a therapist
we know that that we have our blind
spots but this was such a glaring one
but I think I felt a lot of shame around
it how could I of all people have missed
this right so enter Wendell yes so well
so I think Wendell stage left
um so what happens is I don't even
consider going to therapy because it
seems
so clear-cut to me that okay well boy as
my friend said boy did you dodged a
bullet you know good thing you found
this out about him what else was he
hiding right so he became demonized he
became the villain the the boyfriend um
and I just thought well you know I'm
gonna move on from this and and move
forward but I wasn't moving on I was I
was a mess
I mean professionally I was fine like it
was actually respite from the sort of
you know all of the emotional turmoil I
was experiencing but once I would go
home and then once I'd get my son
settled and you know that would be over
I construct myself with my son
there was this gaping hole I mean that's
where boyfriend was write a column
boyfriend in the book that's where he
was and you know I was like unable to
focus I was unable to sleep I was you
know I like tripped on a step in my
garage and like badly bruised my knee I
left my credit card at Target you know I
was just sort of like not there and a
friend of mine who is a therapist said
you know maybe you should talk to
someone
and so I thought right hence the title
of the book and I thought great crisis
management I'll go and I'll I'll get
through this crisis and then I'll be
good to go and of course that's not what
happens and that was your first
experience with doing therapy yourself I
think a lot of people who become
therapists have done their own therapy
um because they're really interested in
understanding themselves better and then
as part of our training we do 500 hours
of therapy but it's I think it's really
different going to a therapist when
you're an intern and you don't really
feel like a therapist yet you very much
feel like the patient
later when you have your own practice
and you've been doing this for a while
when you go back to therapy it feels
very different because you you sort of
have your therapist hat on at the same
time that you're the patient at least
initially for me that's how it was right
and do you feel like you're sort of
calcified around these ideas like oh I
see why you're asking me this like you
know it's sort of like if you're in I
mean you come from television
development like if you've been in the
entertainment industry it's hard to go
to a movie
and just immerse yourself in the story
you're like deconstructing the whole
thing and trying to figure out why they
made these choices is that a similar
experience like going into therapy as a
therapist yeah I know that trick that's
a great example it's almost like like a
magician going to a magician you know
it's like it's like oh I know how that
was done so in my first session I feel
like I know why he's asking certain
questions and I I answer in a way that
again going back to the performative
aspect that will make me look good and
also I don't want to delve into anything
else because I don't think there's
anything else to delve into uh-huh so
hilarious isn't it isn't it how blind we
can be to ourselves you know and and
right in the first session I'm talking
about everything that has happened I'm
telling this story of course so that I
come off as the hero and he come and the
boyfriend comes off as the villain and
but I don't realize I'm doing that I
mean that's the important things I don't
realize I'm doing that it's it's very
it's very much just how I'm telling the
story and what happens is I say at one
point you know you know now I've wasted
all this time and I'm in my 40s and half
my life is over and my therapist gloms
onto that phrase half my life is over
and he keeps trying to direct me back to
that and I'm like I didn't mean anything
but it meant everything right in other
words this this this fear that you're
missing out on some aspect of life and
this was your opportunity to have that
and now it's gone and what does this say
about how you're gonna be living from
Iran Allen well I think what happens is
I think that we think of grief as being
something in the present right like I
miss this person today this person isn't
with me today I miss this person's
presence but we're also grieving the
future we had a whole future with this
person that now has to be rewritten and
so when I said half my life is over
there were other things going on in my
life that I wasn't even really thinking
about because I could distract myself
with I'm going to get married to this
person and that's going to be my future
but there were definitely other things
in my life that I wasn't addressing and
what was really happening was I was
looking for meaning I was looking for
how do I want to spend my time much more
intentionally now the
I'm aware of my mortality now that I'm
in my 40s and I realized that I don't
have forever how do I want to think
about that and I wasn't willing to think
about that until this breakup happened
mm-hmm and so how has that changed like
how do you think about that now versus
then well a couple other things were
going on at the time one was I was
supposed to be writing a book about
happiness that's an interesting story
actually can you share a little bit
about how the book changed from what it
was supposed to be into what it became
yeah so originally I had written this
cover story for the Atlantic called how
to land your kitten therapy and the
subtitle was why our obsession with our
kids happiness might be dooming them two
unhappy adulthood right I want to put a
bookmark on that because I want to get
back to that but go ahead
sure so it went viral it spread like
wildfire it was like the most emailed
story and like that 100 year history of
the Atlantic right and you know
publishers of course wanted me to write
the book version of that and it was this
crazy thing where they offered me a
tremendous amount of money and I was a
single parent and you know this this
could really change the landscape of our
day to day with with you know what they
were offering me and you know was an
easy book to write because I'd already
written the article but I said no and I
said no because I felt like this I
didn't really have a lot more to say I
could easily eke out a book but I felt
like it was there something fraudulent
about it it didn't feel authentic good
it felt like I would be sort of jumping
on the the parenting bandwagon there had
already been a lot of great books
written about that what would mine add
to it and so I said no and everyone
thought I was insane and I said you know
I'm really I was starting out as a
therapist at the time and I said I'm
really interested in what's happening
with the adults I want to write about
the adults and so they said we'll write
a book about happiness which which even
though I didn't want to write a book
about happiness I thought I can like
make it the book that I want to make it
but every and they didn't offer me by
the way that amount of money to do this
I was like doubly stupid and every day I
would sit down to try to write this book
and every day I was paralyzed I could
not write this book because I felt like
it just didn't reflect the nuances of
what I was seeing in the therapy room
what real life was like
you know the studies just can't really
convey that in the same way but my agent
said well if you don't write this book
you'll never write another book because
you turned down the the kid book and now
you're gonna screw up this happiness
book so just write this book and then
you can write what you want but I
absolutely could not do it and I was
telling no one mm-hmm and I was so
ashamed of it I was so ashamed this is
happening I I say in the book that I was
like the closeted gambler who like gets
dressed for work in the morning and says
they're going to the office but drives
to the casino instead my casino is
Facebook right I would just sit on
Facebook right I was dating my boyfriend
and I would like write these fabulously
long witty emails to him but I would not
write this book and I couldn't tell
anybody and you know anyone that would
ask I'd say yeah yeah it's coming along
it's coming along and I didn't even tell
my therapist it was this big secret that
I couldn't tell anyone because I kept
thinking well I'll just at some point
I'll just write it but I couldn't write
so how did you get over that well see
your way through eventually you know
secrets are this thing where they're you
know Karl Yune called secret psychic
poison because they're so corrosive but
also they're all about shame and so this
this was a secret that was all about
shame for me and and the thing about
secrets is once you reveal them
everything opens up for you and so when
I finally told my therapist that this
had been going on I was I felt this
lightness I felt like I don't have to
carry this burden with me like this
albatross around my neck that somebody
else knows this I am NOT alone in this
now and when I told him about it wasn't
that he could solve my problem he didn't
know anything about the publishing world
and in fact he at a certain point gave
me some really not good advice about it
but but what happened was it made me
really have to focus on it once you
reveal the secret you can't deny that it
exists anymore you have to deal with it
and so eventually I canceled the book
contract even though I have to return
the money that was paying for my
internship and but I just it was not it
felt so good to tell my editor I can't
write this board this doesn't feel right
to me it
doesn't feel authentic I feel like this
is not the book I want to write I don't
know if there's another book that I'm
ever gonna write but I'm gonna cancel
this book I am so sorry and my editor
was lovely and in fact when this book
came out maybe you should talk to
someone um she was the first person to
say to me I read your book it's amazing
this was so so much the book you had to
write that's great because I could
easily also see her saying well you'll
never work in this town again like this
it was on strikes and all of that so the
book that you did end up writing was
with a different editor obviously and it
different it was it was with a different
editor um but you know she she she would
you know she very much said I I would
love to work with you but mostly she
said this book she she really isn't
therapy herself and she talked about
like how much it resonated with her
personally that how much it changed her
life just reading the book and that was
so it felt so gratified given how long I
spent in that in that like that secrecy
of I can't tell anybody that this is the
wrong book right and the lesson that I
gather from that is that you know the
creative output has to be authentic to
you like you have to you can't write a
book that you're not feeling right and I
think that somehow you know in some ways
I was even worried about putting it in
maybe you should talk to someone because
I thought who's gonna relate to this
they'll think who's this first personal
problem person who like has a book
contract and she can't write but I think
that it's applicable to anybody because
first of all um I was really struggling
with something about what am I doing
with my life in this profound way you
know so many of us wander especially
when we get to midlife like am I making
the choices I want to make am i living
the way that I want to live am I wasting
my time and so I think with this book it
was about I can't do something that
feels false anymore I have to be true to
who I am
even if I'm going to suffer consequences
and there were significant consequences
by the way it wasn't like this easy
thing where you say okay I'm going to
cancel this book contract it was like we
had to
our lifestyle in order for me to cancel
that that book and and you know it was
it was really hard
Wow well in the book you also at the
same time that you're you know telling
this story about yourself you're also
tracking a couple individuals and their
stories so are these people like
amalgams of several patients are they
are they you know certain individuals
that you then got permission from to
tell their stories or how did that whole
process work that's a great question
so I addressed that in an author's note
but I think a lot of people are curious
about that because especially if they're
in therapy
I think they wonder is somebody gonna
write about me one day or like when
someone comes to see you like is this
gonna end up in a book somewhere or in
the Atlantic like right well first of
all so there are two separate issues one
is I think with a therapist who's not a
writer that's a that's handled
differently in my situation I was a
writer before I became a therapist and
so in my informed consent I say that
people can end up in my writing as long
as I disguise all of the identifying
details in this case
you know I wasn't comfortable writing
about people that I was currently seeing
because I felt that I couldn't go to a
session and then be writing about that
that the lines were too blurred and so I
only wrote about people that I was no
longer seeing I of course got permission
and some of them are composites meaning
I might take something from a very
similar patient that that didn't happen
to the patient that I was writing about
but it was so similar in some and there
was something too revealing about the
original patient so I used this other
example but I think every story is is
very true to the experience of what it
was like to treat that patient and what
that patient went through yeah have you
talked to any of these people since the
book has come out yes I have tell you I
think everybody's really proud of it
I feel like they they feel like I
honored their experience in the book and
also they know why I was writing it
because I wanted to bring I you know I
think what happens in ther
it's you and another person and no one
ever sees it and so much happens in the
therapy room that is transformative or
there are these heroic moments you see
people change in these ways it's almost
like if you could do that time-lapse
photography you know you don't you don't
see like these huge changes every
session but over time you see someone
really transform and I wanted to bring
that experience into you know to a
broader audience
and so I think that the people in the
book are really glad that it's out there
I think it's done so much to kind of
normalize the human experience in a way
that if people are just in rooms talking
privately nobody really knows that other
people are going through something very
similar yeah so no one was like well I
told you you could write about me but I
didn't I didn't know you're gonna write
about that part like it's it's all good
I didn't write about anything that we
hadn't already talked about in therapy
you know it wasn't so I think you know
part of the appeal to of the book I
think is that people get to hear what am
I thinking what am I feeling you know
what is your therapist real it was
really going on your therapist mind and
I think that they're pleased when they
hear that it's not you know we don't
want to be sort of these wizards that
are you know holding these secrets and
so I think that anything that I was
thinking or feeling while I was seeing
these patients I brought up in the room
at the time right or or maybe I didn't
bring it up at the time like with John
who is this very difficult to like
patient at the very beginning he's he's
very narcissistic he's abrasive he
insults me you know I didn't say what I
was thinking in that moment but later on
and you could see in the book when he
says do you think I'm an [ __ ]
right and how I answer that which is
very truthfully about sometimes he comes
off in a way that makes people think
he's an [ __ ] right right and so
John's this bigshot producer you've you
track him you have this Charlotte is
their name the woman who ends up in all
these bad relationships with guys you
have an elderly woman who's
contemplating suicide
what is that how did you decide these
are going to be like the test cases or
what is the identifiable through-line
in in the challenges that they're facing
and grappling with that made it rel
so the narrative that you wanted to tell
I wanted to pick a variety of stories so
all of these people look so different on
the surface different ages different
gender different histories different
personalities different you know time of
life you know everything but I think
that what I do with the stories is I
think that they're all in conversation
with each other because I think that all
of the patients have something in common
with one another and I'm the fifth
patient and I have something in common
with all of them and I think the reader
patient by proxy maybe has something in
common with all of all five of us I
liked their stories because they I think
that they show how you can think
something about a person at the
beginning and how that can change so
much over the course of getting to know
them so I think these were very vivid
examples of that yeah I've read or not
heard you say as well that that there's
this adage that the modality of therapy
is less important than the sort of
connectivity or the bond that you
establish with the person that you're
seeing it's that relationship the
intimacy of that relationship and the
honesty that that it's infused with that
really makes the difference in whether a
patient is gonna see results or not yes
yeah so that's really interesting
because study after study shows that
more than the therapist modality or
their years of experience or you know
the kind of whether they're gender you
know those kinds of things the most
important thing is whether you have
chemistry with your therapist you know
how does it click and I think that
people kind of think that they're coming
in and talking about outside
relationships and they don't realize
that they're also having a relationship
with the therapist and what people do in
the therapy room is a microcosm of what
they do out there so if somebody's
avoidant out there they're gonna be
avoidant with you if somebody you know
goes off on a tangent after tangent to
distract you from you know whatever they
want to talk about they're probably do
that out there too you know if
somebody's a people pleaser they'll do
that with you too and how long
do you think like what is the typical
length of treatment with your patients
like how long do they stay with you and
when is it appropriate to move on is
that just a very personal thing yeah it
totally depends on what they're there
for and what their goals are I think
that there's this misconception about
therapy that people come to therapy they
talk about their childhood ad nauseam I
may never leave and that's just not true
we talk about goals from the very first
session you know why are you here what's
going on and we try to understand more
about what their problem is right away
you know some people are coming in
because they have a very discrete
problem and some people are coming in
because there's something more amorphous
like a feeling of stuckness or a
free-floating anxiety we I just got back
from Europe my wife and I we host these
retreats we've been doing it for a
number of years and we take a group we
have like 45 people in Italy and we took
them through like a seven-day experience
and a lot of it is fun we just you know
we eat amazing food and we meditate and
we do stuff like that but we also do
these workshops and and and try to
really help people confront and grapple
with you know some of the issues that
they face and and one of the things that
was really striking to me about this
experience is that the condition almost
unanimously amongst this group the main
thing that they're confronting in their
lives is this sense this feeling of not
being enough mmm
it was kind of amazing like almost every
single person identified that as like
the thing that they that they really
struggle with and I'm I'm interested in
whether that's mirrored in your own
practice and experience and what that's
about
yeah I I think that that's so true um I
think about Charlotte in the book who's
this young woman who's in her 20s and as
you were saying she keeps hooking up
with the wrong guys including one from
the waiting we're at home she thinks
that's a step up because she says well
at least he's in therapy
right yeah he was yeah you know so her
her her kind of picker was off but but
she also has an alcohol addiction that
that she's not really will
to look at um you know she thinks she's
just kind of a social drinker and and
and she's not and I think that this
feeling of not enough miss you know we
mask it with all kinds of things with
addictive behaviors you see a lot of
people who are you know using all kinds
of substances to mask that even the
Internet one of my colleagues calls the
internet the most effective short term
non prescription painkiller out there I
think we distract ourselves from that
feeling of not enough nests and so when
you're in the therapy room and you don't
have those distractions because we don't
use our phones in there there's nothing
ping dinging vibrating you're not having
a drink
there's nothing just the ivao of the
room that comes out a lot and I think
that people feel so they compare
themselves so much there's so much
comparison going on and I don't know
whether it's worse because of you know
Instagram and Facebook and all of that
but I think people always compare
themselves unfavorably to other people
or if they compare themselves favorably
there's this narcissism like in John's
case right in the book and I always say
to people you need to compare yourself
to yourself that you know where were you
before and where have you come and it
takes away from that sense of like I'm
not good enough because you're not
looking at people out there you're
looking at yourself and a lot of times I
think to people people are so unkind to
themselves yeah so you know I think this
feeling of not enough this has to do it
the way that we talked to ourselves too
you know whose voice is that
I had this one patient write down
everything she said to herself like in
her head for a few days she came back
and she was so embarrassed she almost
like she was like hesitant to read it to
me she's like I can't read this out loud
I can't say this out loud and when she
did it was like she's like I'm a bully
like I'm horrible to myself so many of
us don't notice the ways that we talked
to ourselves and it comes from this
feeling of like what's wrong with you
you know we literally say things like
that to ourselves oh yeah I mean and the
relationship that we have with ourselves
we would never have with
another human being nobody would talk to
him I've talked to us like that we
wouldn't be friends with that person
right and and I'm cured I'm wondering
whether there's something specific
that's going on in our culture that has
made this so acute right now I mean
certainly I think social media fuels
this but maybe something else outside of
that as well I mean I think I think
there's this sense of disconnection it
knows so no matter what people come in
with I feel like there's this underlying
sense of loneliness even if people are
you know they're they're happily married
or they they have lots of friends or
family people tend to feel disconnected
from the people that are important to
them you know so many of us are not like
just sitting face-to-face with somebody
else sometimes the only experience they
get of that with no phones nothing else
distracting them the only experience
they get of that really is that 15
minutes in the therapy room I also think
that the signals that we receive are
confusing and overwhelming like it's
it's no longer okay to just be a mom or
to be a professional like you have to be
an amazing mom who who does all the
right things so that your kid doesn't
end up in therapy you have to be a
successful professional you have to be
able to show up at all your kids events
and and now I think that that has
spilled over into expectations on men as
well no longer is the man just the
provider he's got to be the amazing
ever-present dad who also has to go to
all the stuff and and it's hard to check
every box and feel like you're showing
up and present and a hundred percent in
all of these categories so it's almost
impossible to not beat yourself up if
you're not you know meeting your own
expectations that you set for yourself
and all of these many categories right
well we always feel like we're falling
short but the question is whose
expectations are those you know they are
those are those expectations out there
or are they your own you know and I
think there's also when you talked about
men there's this gender difference I
think where men come in and you know
they talk about all the things you're
talking about they have the same issues
that women do about you know what's
going on in their marriages and what are
they like as a parent
and how are they feeling about their
careers and how do they feel about their
own their own you know relationship with
their own parents and siblings and they
have all the same issues but they they
don't have the outlet in which to talk
about them so men will come in and
they'll say I've never told anybody this
before and then what they tell me is so
like at first it's like so mild to me
you know it's kind of like that was the
secret you were holding like you know I
don't like my neighbour you know it's
like something you know um women will
come in and they'll say I've never told
anybody this before except for my mother
my sister my best friend's right so
they've told like a handful of people
but when we actually start talking about
these things the men and the women
they're talking about such similar
things as what am I like as a partner as
a parent as a worker as any of the as a
human you know
and so I think it's it's really
important that people are feeling more
open to these conversations because
people are really struggling by
themselves and they're not talking to
anybody about it yeah I mean just
because I'm a man I have that
perspective but one of the things that
that I think about a lot is you know
what is it like what does it mean to be
a present responsible loving husband
father you know community oriented
person like I'm supposed to be masculine
but I'm also supposed to be sensitive
and can I hug that person
I probably shouldn't hug anyone anymore
like what are the rules like you know I
it's it can be kind of disorienting and
confusing and what I find myself doing
is kind of just withdrawing you know and
isolating rather than confronting these
things and trying to figure out like how
to best navigate all these landmines
that are out there I see a lot of
couples in my practice and that's
something that happens with them too
which is they get confused about what
the partners expectations are of them
and so then they just they feel like I
can't win you know and so they just
withdraw it's it's you know that's our
response to feeling like well there's
nothing I can do so you know they it's
like learned help
yeah you wrote an article about it was
it was an argument against equality
within the relationship within the
marriage equality no it was the wrong
way of saying it was for equality yeah
um it was it was a peaceful New York
Times magazine and it was about this
research that showed that in a marriage
when men did more feminine chores that
the couples had less sex and when they
did more when the when the kind of
household duties were divided more along
sort of traditional gender lines like
the man will like fix the roof or the
car or take out the trash and the woman
will do the laundry and the dishes let's
say if they had more sex that doesn't
mean it was a better marriage right that
just it's just about quantity it doesn't
say anything about quality
it just says like hey we have these like
programs inside of us about gender and
they're they're very the very
deep-seated so you know sometimes women
might not see their husband as as sexy
even though they say that like if you
see your husband doing the dishes you
like you feel really really good about
him right but are you does that does
that increase your sexual desire right
and so that was the question in the
article and it wasn't it wasn't it
didn't come to any conclusion it was
sort of like here's the research here's
what a lot of people are saying about it
we don't really know what this means yet
I had to be a little controversial
though well yeah of course because you
know I think a lot of people interpreted
it the way that you were first
describing it which is that you know
that somehow oh no somebody's making a
case for going back to these traditional
marriages that that were really unfair
to women yeah that's not at all what
what you know the article was suggesting
let's talk about the Atlantic piece
about how to keep your kids out of
therapy
as a parent of a bunch of kids this is
something I think about a lot it's a
it's actually like a running joke with
my fifteen-year-old daughter every time
something happens I'm like well this is
the thing you're gonna you're gonna be
in therapy
and you know I find myself often
believing that I'm parenting in contra
pits contra position to the way that my
my parents parent at me like reactionary
like they did that I don't think that
worked I'm gonna go in the other
direction maybe a little too far in the
other direction and yet at the same time
I'll catch myself doing the exact same
thing yes my parents did so what I think
I'm doing what I'm actually doing when I
have enough self-awareness to understand
my impulses and behavior are very
different things there's this great
paper that came out decades ago called
the ghost in the nursery by Selma
Freiburg and it's about how we think
that we're gonna be different from our
parents but actually it's really hard
not to do exactly what they did it's not
it's right it's it's offense hot it's
like a fascinating paper I highly
recommend it
so yeah you know but I think what
happens is like the the pendulum swung
too far in the other direction and it's
great that I think people are having
these much more much richer I think
relationships with their kids and really
understanding their inner lives but what
happens is we're so worried about you
know any displeasure that our kids are
experiencing any you know anxiety or
sadness you know any of the logical
consequences that come with like you
didn't get the role in the school play
or you didn't get into that College
because you actually didn't work hard or
or just you didn't get into that College
because lots of people applied and
that's what happens in life you're gonna
apply for jobs and you might be
completely qualified but you're not
going to get that job but I think you
know parents are you know they really
have a hard time tolerating any
discomfort that their children are
experiencing yeah it's not good no it's
not because generation of people that
that have no ability to navigate
difficulty in setbacks which does not
set themselves up well for life right so
when I wrote that article it was because
I was doing my internship and I saw all
these people coming in right out of
college saying my parents were the best
they're my best friends they they made
everything so easy for me I have nothing
to complain about and yet I
feel unequipped to be an adult yeah yeah
yeah as a parent your child shouldn't be
your best friend that's that's a strange
violation of emotional boundaries that
says more about your needs as a parent
than what's in the child's best
interests right there is this there is I
think this sense especially because
nowadays I think a lot of people are
feeling you know lonelier because we
don't have community in the same way so
in the past you could walk outside and
the kids would play and the adults would
talk and the kids would be like doing
their own thing and the adults would be
doing their own thing right like nearby
but now it's like if you want to have
some kind of social interaction you have
to like make a plan and it might not
necessarily intersect with your kids
plans and so we don't have like
neighborhoods community in the same way
a lot of people are really lonely they
don't have a lot of people to talk to
and so what happens is they end up you
know like getting a lot of emotional
gratification from being the helicopter
parents like you know we're gonna go to
music class now and then we're gonna go
do this class we're gonna go do this and
because they don't really have any adult
time yeah
Lisa do more and and Susan David both
talked about this I mean Susan calls it
emotional resilience and and Lisa talks
about you know the the importance of
allowing our kids to fail and putting
them in that position so that they
experience how to develop that kind of
resilience at a young age if they're
fully formed in their 20s and they're
meeting resistance for the first time in
their lives they're ill-equipped to
manage it and it causes all kinds of you
know breakdowns and I think we see that
now getting played out on college
campuses at the moment yeah there's even
I think it was at the University of
Chicago they have this person at the end
of when you drop off your kid for
freshman year that the parents weren't
willing to separate from their kids so
they said they had the parents like go
in this one procession to literally
extract them from their children and
bouncers you need to leave right like
all the parents come this way and all
the kids go this way so the parents
can't accompany the kids to the dorm and
like the kids need to go and meet each
other and bond and do all their freshman
orientation activities and the parents
weren't willing to leave so the
actually having fun you know a protocol
you know that's laid out now that's of
me and so you know I think that that
says a lot about how things have changed
from one generation to the next and it's
not that one you know like the old the
old way was better it's just that I
think there's a happy medium you know
like you can you can have this this rich
relationship with your child but you
also have to prepare your child for
adulthood and you have to have your own
life so many parents nowadays they don't
have a life at all you know they don't
have a time when like they are they have
their own social life they're afraid to
leave their kids you know
Minoo their whole social life is about
you know what am i doing for where I
might where's my kid need to be at this
moment and and besides the the sort of
inability to navigate challenges later
in life what are some of the other you
know what is the symptom ology that ends
up showing up in these kids later in
life they can't access their feelings so
when they were sad um you know let's go
to Disneyland or or if something
happened that made them sad like well at
lunch so-and-so wouldn't sit with me
today the phone call happens to the
school well I understand them all the
time right someone's fixing their
problem for them we're gonna erase your
sadness right now we don't want you to
experience that but the thing is if the
kid could experience that they could
actually problem-solve - they would come
up with a good solution or they would
experience rejection which is part of
life and so you say okay what is my kid
gonna do well your kid will probably
find other friends your kid will
probably find a way to eat lunch with
somebody where it's a comfortable
situation and why is that so difficult
for us as parents to take that step back
um I think that part of it is that we
remember how hard it was when we were
kids like if we experienced rejection
and we project that on to our kids yeah
like that's going to scar you and and it
won't necessarily do that if you can
support your kid and say that was really
it sounds really hard you know what
happened at lunch
you know and then you just let your kid
talk and they'll come up with something
but if your kid thinks you're gonna fix
it every time every time something goes
wrong they're gonna come to you and say
I'm sad about this I didn't like what
happened here and they're gonna expect
that you're gonna either give them a
solution or you're gonna fix it you know
by calling the school or calling the
other parents with whom they had a
conflict yeah and then they did they
have no acuity for doing that themselves
right and then they get into the
workplace and what happens is people say
these kids are like you know they they
have a sense of entitlement you know
they don't think that they should be
doing menial tasks because everyone told
them they were so special and they were
so wonderful and all of a sudden it's
like what do you mean I need to get you
coffee
you know I I have a college degree yeah
where is like that was expected before
that was part of the job you want to
learn the job okay part of it is you're
gonna have to do things that feel
useless yeah but at the same time you're
gonna be in these meetings yeah so you
get the coffee but you get to sit in in
that meeting and learn how to produce
that show or how to negotiate that deal
or whatever you're doing yeah I mean in
your own personal case it's like you
went to Yale you went to Stanford and
then you became an assistant in
Hollywood right and ya know what that
looks like yes it was not glamorous yeah
I want to talk about that in a minute
but but to kind of stay on this track so
outside of the helicopter parenting and
the you know the tiger mom kind of
scenario what about the other side of
the spectrum like I feel like with my 15
year old I've given my wife and I have
given her a very long leash like we're
probably on the other side of that
equation what are the perils of too much
freedom and allowing this person like a
very wide berth to experience their life
you want to give them enough freedom
where you know they're ready for it but
or or maybe they're you know where
they're comfortable with it you want it
to come from them too right so you know
my son is 13 and I leave him for periods
of time right meaning like all go do
something I might go have dinner with a
friend
and he's doing his homework at home and
I'm close by
some people say wait no one's with your
your kid he was like when I was 13 I was
actually babysitting yeah like you know
when I was 13 I was the person who was
taking care of the little kids in the
house
you know he's perfectly capable of
sitting at home and doing his homework
and and he's a really reliable kid like
I know he's not gonna be like playing
for at night while I'm gone right so you
know I mean you want to give them that
like he likes that they develop a sense
of agency over their own lives and they
feel yeah and there's a confidence about
that like you know and that he likes it
he's like oh no one's here this is
really cool right he gets to choose how
he spends his time you know and he knows
what is a he doesn't just have to do his
homework like he can he can do other
things I was into to raising that child
such that they do make the choice to do
their homework when you're not there and
they're not on fortnight I think that
giving giving kids freedom makes them
more responsible that if you if you if
you're if the leash is too tight they're
gonna be like I never get to do this I
have to do this any minute I get freedom
I'm gonna do all these other things he
has enough freedom where you know he
knows if he has time he'll do his
homework um he wants to do his homework
because he doesn't want to like you know
leave it to the last minute and then
feel stressed so it's about his stress
level it's for him not for me right um
but he's not just gonna sit and do his
homework I mean he'll do other things
like he might draw he might read a book
or he might you know who knows what do
you know my phone he might no he doesn't
yeah but he's getting one this year
probably I would say like bye-bye eighth
grade it's gonna be it's gonna be oh we
have an interesting we have a contract
you do what tell us so I'm writing it
I'm writing it because we're in the
process of negotiating getting one um
it's just a contract that's like here
it's like one page it's not like you
know it's kind of like the basic rules
like here's here's what you've got the
phone for here's how to use it you know
here's how not to use it you know if I
find you doing these things here's what
happens to the phone it just out very
clear so there's no there's no question
about certain apps that can be used and
others that can't or it's not that
specific it's kind of like
you know you will be respectful of
people when you use the phone like
you're not gonna like say mean things
about people in social media or texting
to your friends like you're not gonna
you're not gonna use it for that purpose
you you know it doesn't belong you know
like after a certain hour it goes off
you know basic things about like when I
call you need to answer those kinds of
things yeah it's tough I mean you know I
I struggle with my own attachment and
addiction issues with the mobile device
and I'm seeing it played out and in in
my kids and particularly my 15 old
daughter like it's it's just so powerful
it has the capacity to just override all
of your better impulses and it does it
you hostage so I think the rules are
super important and then consistently
enforcing them and applying them right
like we don't have phones at the table
ever mmm that just we don't because
we're having a meal right um you know
and I think that people think that's
weird you know that we're Amish or
something you know it's like it's like
we're not it's just that it's it's Meal
Time like why why should our phones be
at the table so just things like that
but we're not you know but we use
technology I use technology all the time
so it's not being anti technology it's
just saying technology has a place in
our lives but we don't want to drown in
it right well let's talk a little bit
about how you got to this place because
you have a very interesting unique
circuitous route to doing what you do
yeah I always used to say that I was
either very versatile or very confused
more confused I think than versatile
because I'm actually not that versatile
but the thing is like it's that thing
where you look in the rearview mirror
and it all lines up perfectly because
all these things inform me inform each
other so well that's right so I didn't
realize yeah I didn't realize that I was
actually doing the same thing so I was
basically working in story and the human
condition just from different angles so
when I when I started out after college
I started working in the entertainment
business and I was doing motion picture
film development and then I moved over
to do TV development and I was like a
baby executive
n-b-c the first year that two very
successful shows happen to premiere one
of them was friends and one of them was
ER
so you I know you worked on ER did you
work on friends also so once it went
over to current programming not really
because I was in development but in
development yes and so that first year
yes and you know it was interesting
because in ER we had this medical
consultant who was this ER doc and he
would you know make sure that everything
was accurate you know that the trauma
Bay scenes were choreographed correctly
and that the terms were used correctly
and I would hang out in the ER with him
cuz it's really fascinated by that and
at a certain point I would I would hang
out there a little more than I should
have been and he said to me you know you
seem much more interested in what we're
doing here then what you're doing back
at the office and he's like maybe you
should go to medical school and I was
like 27 and I said I I wasn't even a
science major I was a French literature
major this is I'm not going to medical
school
but but the more and I thought this is a
hobby just a hobby but then you know I
started hanging out with like other
doctors you know in other hospitals and
I was like obsessed with it and it was
sort of like in when you're telling
stories on television
i loved TR because there were these very
authentic feeling rich human experiences
and i think that's why the show is such
a success but then you see the real
stories you know when you go into the ER
you go into you know wherever you're
shadowing these doctors and it was like
wow this is this is what it's all about
you know you're at that stage in life
you think this is what it's all about
and would you come back from one of
those experiences and share with the
writers room what you'd experienced and
did any of that end up in any of the
shows really Joe was the one who Joe
this consultant was the one who
interfaced with them in that way but but
I would come back you know certainly you
could add your two cents but really it
was more of a personal thing it was like
oh this is fascinating and at a certain
point I realized that I couldn't deny
that this was not just a hobby
uh-huh
um and so I took all the pre-med classes
and I went up to Stanford for medical
school that's crazy so you're 27 at the
time well now I'm like now I'm like
almost 30 I had to take all the classes
is such a huge life shift and commitment
to take on at that stage in life yeah it
was so did you do the pre-med you took
like the pre-med corps all the courses
that you had to take while you were
still working at NBC no I left NBC and I
started I started writing I because
which is funny because again the writing
I was so interested in I think seeing
all the writers when you're at the
network I felt like oh I really like
writing I don't want to write on a show
but I decided to kind of do journalism
like I could freelance and then I could
take my pre-med classes so that's what I
did so I supported myself with the
freelancing and then I took the pre-med
classes and just down here in Los
Angeles
right yeah and then um and I took the
MCAT and I applied to med schools and
you know I'm this you know I was old at
that point old in in the sense of like
most people applying our seniors in
college
and I you know and and at the time I was
really I didn't really know what I
wanted to do in medicine I just I really
I didn't realize at the time that what I
was in love with was like these
relationships that you have with the
patients and and and you know being
involved in these incredible life
moments and so I went up to medical
school and all of my professor started
talking about this newfangled thing
called managed care and you know they
were really frustrated because they had
had these practices that were very much
their calling and all of a sudden they
had these 15-minute visits and you know
the insurance companies were telling
them what to do and there they had to
see so many people in the course of a
day and the whole landscape was changing
and I realized that I wasn't gonna be
able to do the kind you know had this
like fantasy of being the family doctor
who guides people through their lives
and this romantic idea just got pulled
out from underneath you it did exactly
that relationship was gonna look like it
did and so and while I was there you
know because I had I had started writing
I thought well
I'll go be a journalist and I can really
get involved in people's stories in this
deeper way and so I did and I was a
journalist for about a decade when I had
my baby left medical school after like
two years right
yeah okay and you're just I have to just
say like you you're somebody who when
you set your mind to do something like
you do it you're like I'm gonna go to
medical school and then you're at
Stanford School I'm gonna be a
journalist and then you're publishing
everywhere like you know it's it's in
when you look at it that way like when I
look back on it I think it's kind of
amazing um but at the time it was kind
of like everything felt like there was
some internal motor that said like you
need to go to medical school right you
need to and then I got there and I
realized it wasn't gonna be the right
thing and you need to do this as a
journalist because my passion which I
didn't realize was it was all about
story in the human condition from
whatever angle whether it was like you
know on ER or whether it was later you
know in medical school or later as a
journalist but then I had my my child
and you know like we were talking about
parenting parenting can be really
isolating nowadays yeah and I realized
like the UPS guy would come with all of
his deliveries and I got a lot of
deliveries at the time and I'd be like
how about those diapers and you have
kids and how's the weather and he would
literally be backing up to his big brown
truck and I'm like I need some kind of
adult interaction in my profession every
day uh-huh and I love my child by the
way PS you know I love you honey
but but you know it was like it was like
there was something that was missing and
so I called up the Dean at Stanford
Medical School I had become very close
with her when I was there and I said
maybe I should come back and do
psychiatry because I was very clear that
like I love like the way the mind works
that's what I was really into at the
time but also sorry I don't mean to
interrupt but like a normal impulse
might have been like well maybe I'll
join a book club or I'll go to yoga or
something like that you're like I'm
going back to medical school I
I wanted to do it in a in a really like
intentional way you know it wasn't it
wasn't like a hobby it was like I want
to do this as my calling so I said maybe
I should come back and do psychiatry
because then I could you know do the
things that I'm doing but I would have
interactions with people and they'd be
meaningful and she said you know I think
that I remember how you talked about
this in medical school and I think that
if you went back had to do finished
medical school do internship do
residency with a baby with a toddler and
then you'd basically be prescribing
celexa and 15-minute intervals you could
do talk therapy but why do you want to
go through all of that when you can get
a graduate degree in clinical psychology
focus less on medication management and
focus on these you know the kind of
relationships that you want to have as a
therapist and it was one of those things
where you know how people talk about aha
moments and we don't get very many of
them in life this was one of them where
it was like all the puzzle pieces
somebody just put the missing piece of
the puzzle into the puzzle and now I can
see it and I thought yes that's exactly
what I need to do and that's what I did
and I realized that I went from telling
people stories as a journalist to
helping people change their stories as a
therapist and and I still do both you
know I wouldn't want to do one without
the other so I have a part-time practice
and I have a part-time journalism career
and has your experience as a journalist
made you a better therapist absolutely
no they they very much inform each other
and explain that like in what way like
how do they complement each other I feel
like as a therapist I'm almost working
as an editor so people come in with a
story as we've talked about and the
version of the story that they come in
with usually has some problems with it
like a first draft does and you know
it's sort of like well is the
protagonist moving forward or is the
protagonist going in circles and who are
the heroes in this story and who are the
villains in the story like in my example
boyfriend was the villain at first but
as you read the book you realize oh wait
a minute he's not a villain he's a
really good guy and you watch that
change and you see like I was
responsible for part of this too and so
when people come in I want to help them
edit their stories they need a massive
rewrite usually that's what's
being them stuck and so I think when we
look at character motivation arc of a
person's life that's embedded in story
so I think that that's how you know
they're they're kind of in conversation
with each other and I think as a
journalist and as a writer even writing
this book you know you look at well how
am i telling this story is this true to
the experience is this emotionally true
mm-hmm yeah they're all so different
though I mean as a journalist you're
trying to track down some objective
truth and you have to keep some distance
between yourself and that story whereas
the patient-therapist relationship is a
much more intimate one I mean there's
boundaries as well but where does where
does the journalist path and the
therapist path kind of part ways or
distinguish themselves from each other
well I would say they're not as
different as you think they are because
I feel like as a as a journalist you do
insert yourself into the story a little
bit
you're not the story but you're forming
a relationship with that person when
you're asking those questions and and I
think as a therapist I have a lot of I
have a lot of I would say training but
also it's an instinct after a while like
how do you get people to talk about what
you really want them to be talking about
well you can weaponize that right like
if you're chasing down a story and
you're you're interviewing someone and
they're being evasive you have a tool
box to try to get them to reveal
something they perhaps might not
ordinarily do because you know exactly
how to get to it yeah I wouldn't say
weaponize it though because I feel like
it's his story it's that well know but I
also feel like I don't have like I don't
have a malicious intent right that I
want to tell the story because it's an
important story not because I want to
make them look bad and whatever I tell
about them is not going to make them
look bad because I don't tell those
kinds of stories so basically I want to
get to the truth of their story and so
how do I get to the truth of their story
even though they may feel reluctant to
share that and what do you decide how do
you make decisions about what write
about as a journalist usually SOT
there's some question that I played out
in different ways in the culture and
I want to tackle it from a different
angle so like in the parenting story for
example right lots of people had written
about helicopter parenting I was
interested in what's happening with all
these people who are coming in to see me
and they had these great childhood you
know it's the opposite of what people
think of therapy and they're they're
depressed or anxious or you know unable
to kind of function in the ways that
they hope to in the story that you were
talking about with the New York Times
about you know like what's happening in
marriages I'm really interested I see a
lot of couples and I was curious about
this that on the one hand people will
say to their husbands like you know I
want you to be more sensitive I want you
to tell me how you're really feeling and
then they do and then in the therapy
room the women will be like oh my god he
cried you know it's like I want you to
be sensitive but not so sensitive that I
feel unsafe well why does that make you
feel unsafe you know what is sort of
this hardwired gender idea that they
have you're asking for one thing and
then when he gives it to you you're
repulsed by it yeah in your practice
treating treating couples what is the
what is a recurring thing that you that
you see like what are what are people
struggling with in terms of how to
relate to each other and and have
productive relationships I think partly
um for younger couples they don't have a
lot of experience relating because they
grew up in sort of the age of technology
they didn't date in the same way that
earlier generations dated so they have
less experience with like what happens
when relationships don't look like the
movies and you know they don't have a
lot of maybe communication skills they
have a lot of unrealistic expectations
of what their partner can provide for
them or what a partner should provide
for them you know he's got to be like or
she has to be my best friend my you know
rock my world in bed every single time
you know read my mind have you know be
telepathic you know not not hurt me in
any way you know they just don't
understand sort of like what happens in
relationships they don't understand sort
of what we call rupture and repair that
people hurt each other or make mistakes
all the time
the question is how do you guys deal
with that and how do you repair it what
what do you think about in treating
those people are counseling those people
like what is a picture of a healthy what
is a healthy relationship look like in
terms of how two people are interacting
productively I think when they can hear
each other and understand that
everything that they each of them thinks
is subjective
that you know like when somebody like if
you see a couple and they'll say here's
what happened and the other person says
here's what happened both things
happened this is the experience of each
person so they're parallel stories that
happened and there's some like in the
Venn diagram there's some overlap where
they agree on sort of job but they had
different experiences of the same
situation and so a lot of times people
will say something like well you don't
listen to me and I we say to that person
if you want someone to listen to you ask
yourself how well do I listen to that
person oh yeah people don't want to hear
that but it's so helpful and when they
do hear it they it really makes them
stop cold in the therapy room because
they're not hearing it in a critical way
they're hearing like oh wow I didn't
think about that like I'm talking so
much because I'm trying to make my point
I'm trying to get this person to hear me
by talking a lot and the way that I can
get this person to hear me is by
listening to that person and when I was
training a supervisor said to me you
have two ears in one mouth there's a
reason for that ratio well I think I
think that it's it's very difficult to
not project upon that other person this
idea of who you think they are and who
they should be and mentally we create
this framework and a rulebook for how
that person should behave to meet our
needs right and this is a sort of an
unspoken social contract that's going in
two directions and it's inevitable that
that contract is going to get broken and
when we're projecting too much onto that
other person that's what creates
conflict and heartbreak and all the rest
and my wife and I have been together for
a very long time and one of the things
that we've worked hard on is to
have our own independent lives that that
you know we're not looking to the other
person to you know quote unquote you
know complete each other like we are
complete you know self-sustaining
organisms in our own right and you know
we we navigate the world together but
also separately and kind of respect each
other in that in our in our in our in
our discrete separate paths yeah that's
so important and I also think that a lot
of couples they they don't understand
that they need to get they need to have
their lives together before they meet
this person I don't mean totally
together you're gonna evolve and you
change in the course of your marriage
right you know you're you you you're a
different person in your 20s than you
are in your thirties forties fifties
sixties its etc but I think that if you
feel like this whole or there's
emptiness and you feel like this other
person is going to further that for you
well that's a recipe for a disaster but
that's an epidemic I mean that is just
what so many people do yeah I also think
that people going back to you know what
people attributing something like the
reason that somebody's acting away
toward you so many people are wrong
they're just flat-out wrong like you you
when you did this it was because you
wanted bit it's like no that's not why I
said that or did that right and they
really need to hear how wrong their
projections can be for them to start
having different kinds of conversations
so they aren't you know often people are
having basically the same fight every
week so I don't do couples therapy where
we analyze the fight of the week I think
that gets us nowhere I want to know the
pattern underlying it so that you don't
keep having these kinds of fights I
don't need to know the specifics of
every single fight I want to see what is
this pattern what is this conflict that
you repeatedly get into that creates the
different fights that you're having hmm
why is it that we tend to seek out
partners that reflect the way that we
were parented yeah when it when it's you
know when it was unhealthy like yeah you
know the example in your book of the
woman who ends up in all these
relationships you know that that that
mirrors her experience as a young girl
right it's almost like what you said
about parenting that we say we're gonna
do the opposite of what our parents did
and that we do sort of the same thing
the same thing it's the thing about that
is with Charlotte she doesn't realize
that she keeps saying well none of these
men you know I can't seem to find a guy
who wants a relationship but she keeps
picking these guys who are very much
like her parents Laura you know which is
sort of like sometimes they're very
present and sometimes they're not
they're always keeping her guessing and
we grow up and we say I don't want that
that felt bad I want something different
but it's almost like we have radar for
the familiar yeah and if you're not
aware of it
you're gonna keep choosing people who
tap into that very familiar feeling of
home it almost feels like home to even
if home was miserable right you're like
I'm functional right you're like we're
like oh that feels kinda like my teddy
bear that feels like my teddy bear
I recognize that and the problem is that
if you go outside of your comfort zone
if she were to pick somebody who was
available to her and present and wanted
a relationship she would feel like what
she would do with him when she's oh I'm
not attracted to her Rona it feels
foreign if I can't we be attracted to
the person that's good for us because it
felt foreign to her right it was like
because it's scary to go outside of your
comfort zone all of a sudden you're in
this strange land and you don't know the
the customs in this land you don't speak
the language in this land it's so much
more comfortable to cling to the
familiar of them oh I know what that's
like to be on edge and wonder if he
calls I know exactly what that's like I
grew up like that right what's confusing
about that though I can understand
intellectually like oh that's that's
uncomfortable and confusing but why the
then there's the the the sexual
attraction component to it it's like why
am i sexually attracted to the person
that's not good for me and I can't find
myself sexually attracted to the person
that you know like how does how does the
sexuality aspect of it get confounded
with the other confusing part well I
think the attraction is holistic it's
not you know it's not compartmentalized
like that so you say like I'm really
drawn to this person like like it
doesn't even have to be sexual in the
sense of people pick friends like that
to they'll pick like friends who are not
rely
or friends who were kind of flakier
friends who are addicted if their
parents were addicted you know they tend
to kind of recapitulate whatever they
grew up and until they really really
understand it and I don't mean just have
an awareness of it in the book I say
insight is the booby prize of therapy
because you can have all the insight in
the world like oh now I understand why I
keep picking those guys but if you don't
make changes out in the world ie pick
other guys the insight is useless so
many times people in couples therapy
will say like oh now I understand why
you know I get really triggered by that
that when you do that you know and why I
react that way but then they don't
change anything yeah well you're wasting
your time if you're not going to change
anything so I think in therapy you have
to be both vulnerable and accountable so
you have to be vulnerable but you also
have to be accountable for what are you
gonna do with the work that we're doing
how are you gonna make some tangible
changes in your behavior when you leave
here the change part is so hard right
and people don't realize that they think
oh it's positive change so it should be
easy because people want something
better to happen but with every change
comes loss yeah the revelation feels
like progress but it's actually not
doing anything I mean I've been sober a
long time and you know the adage in
12-step is self enough self-knowledge
will avail you nothing right and when
people say to me like well why do you
think you were an alcoholic like what
happened when you're it's and I've
learned like it's interesting to explore
that but I could spend all of my time
trying to deconstruct that and it
actually doesn't help you know it
doesn't it doesn't inform how I'm gonna
make decisions going forward I have this
toolbox now and I apply these tools to
how I make decisions and how I run
things by other people that have allowed
me to maintain my sobriety and and you
know become a more productive member of
society so for me it's about like the
actionable tools and I think it is like
it's so difficult for people to change
and in my experimental experience like I
didn't change until I was in you know
the pain of the pain of continuing on
the path that I was on exceeded the fear
of you know
the unknown should I change right so you
know what is that like like how do you
get people short of having to have some
you know Cataclysm in their life to make
those adjustments and actually you know
put your information and your insight
into forward motion there was something
that my therapist said to me that I
write about in the book where he said
you know where I was like just feeling
trapped by all of these sort of external
circumstances and I wasn't willing to
make changes I wasn't willing to look at
what I could do differently and he said
you remind me of this cartoon and it
said this prisoner shaking the bars
desperately trying to get out but on the
right and the left the bars are open
uh-huh and it was like you know at first
I thought is really cheesy but but then
I thought wait a minute he's right
because so many of us would rather be
the prisoner shaking the bar saying I
can't do anything about this we don't
want to look that it's open on the right
or the left because then if we walk out
and we go into the sunlight and there
are no bars and we're free with freedom
comes responsibility
and now we have to take responsibility
for our lives we can't say oh the
problem is you know that I'm trapped
here right now it's like anything that
happens is I'm responsible for that
and so change is hard for that reason
you know it's it's easier to feel
trapped in the whatever childhood drama
you know that your your reenacting then
to actually do something different where
you might have to be responsible for
your choices and when you're when you're
when you're trapped in that paradigm you
can get a lot of idiot compassion coming
your way yes and that feels so delicious
doesn't it yeah yeah it's so good right
yeah it's such a victim yeah I know you
are isn't it terrible mm-hmm yeah but
the idea that you could be free which is
awesome is terrifying yeah yeah we don't
know and especially if you grew up
without that kind of freedom without the
emotional freedom um all of a sudden you
feel like I don't know how to do this I
don't know how to be free it's it you
know it just feels too risky to go out
there and do something different do you
think everybody should be in therapy
people since the book came out everybody
asked me that and and they do and and I
think it's interesting I'm not you know
I think everybody can benefit from
therapy I don't think everybody needs to
be in therapy you know but I do think
this I think that so many times people
come to therapy later than they should
meaning that you know we we think about
our physical well-being different from
our emotional well-being so if somebody
feels like something is wrong with their
body like you're having chest pain
you'll probably go to the cardiologist
before you have a massive heart attack
but if somebody feels like oh something
doesn't feel right emotionally we tend
to ignore it or minimize it you know
well I have a roof over my head and food
on the table so I don't really need help
and what happens is they think that they
can just make the feelings go away or
not pay attention to them but when you
don't pay attention to feelings they
become stronger and they come out you
know in a behavior in a irritability or
in a short-tempered Nisour in a you know
self-defeating self-sabotaging way of
being in the world whatever it is or
inability to sleep whatever and so
people then don't come to therapy until
they're having some kind of crisis and
it's like they're having an emotional
heart attack like why would why would
you wait that long because you've
suffered unnecessarily for all of this
time and also it's harder to treat once
you're really you know once you've
gotten to that point yeah yeah I mean
there's no downside
well time money um the the big the
biggest downside I think for people even
though there are logistical problems
that are very real is that a lot of
people kind of unconsciously know that
if they go to therapy they night might
need to make changes right yeah you know
it's like if I go to therapy like I
might need to do something different in
my life I might need to be uncomfortable
and I don't want to be uncomfortable so
I'd rather just you know just keep
things the way they are right status quo
and so what's uh like what's next for
you well I'm still writing my I have my
practice and I have my weekly dear
therapist column that I write for The
Atlantic every Monday
um and I am about to do a TED talk that
are you writing yes Wow yeah can you
talk about what it is or is that under
wraps well you can I'm taping it in
September nice yeah is that for like
TEDMED or no the main time maintain oh
wow yeah that's exciting the red circle
oh my goodness are you nervous about
that not yet but I know I will yeah yeah
yeah that's a super cool opportunity
yeah and and tell me about the the the
the book is being developed into a
television show yeah oh yeah so this
brings you back full circle once again
right and all these worlds intersect for
yourself yeah and I'm really glad that I
worked in television before because one
of the things I think about as we're
adapting the book for television is that
you know I think that a lot of the ways
that therapists have been portrayed in
the media give people the wrong
impression and it keeps people from
getting help and so you know I think
that therapists are either like you know
like the very distant cold therapist or
they're like the hot mess the train
wreck right and the therapist that I
know or neither and so um this is this
television show is about a person who
happens to be a therapist but it's not
about a therapist if that makes sense
meaning she happens to be a therapist
and so you meet her family you meet you
know the people that she sees you you
obviously are in the therapy room but
it's not about like all of the cliches
and tropes about therapy this happens to
be her job right so it's not like in
treatment no sure you know yeah and
where are you in the in the stages of
development it's being written it's
being written right now yeah are you
writing it no I want it to be good all
your your entertainment contacts from
back in the day well no the project so
it's Eva Longoria's company that's
producing it and so it's all it's all
through that yeah yeah that's exciting
well super nice to talk to you so nice
to talk about sharing with me today
it's fascinating I can talk about
therapy psychotherapy all day long the
book is amazing check it out maybe you
should talk to someone
coming to a TED stage soon right right
if people want to connect with you they
go to your website right Lori Gottlieb
comm where else I'm also at Lori
Gottlieb one on Twitter and I just
started using Instagram I still don't
know how to use it but I met Lori
Gottlieb underscore author and if
anybody wants to give me a tutorial I
welcome it I'm happy to do that with a
thirteen year old about to get an iPhone
I think you're gonna have to get up to
speed
that's right maybe snapchat too well he
told me yeah he doesn't think that that
he says Twitter's not cool Instagram
he's not sure if it's cool snapchat is
apparently cool much snapchat yeah that
age I think so anyway I have to talk
[Laughter]
[Music]